In questo capitolo esploreremo
come i computer quantistici e classici
lavorano insieme per risolvere una delle sfide più importanti
nella scienza: stimare accuratamente l'energia di molecole e materiali
Possiamo raggiungere questo obiettivo
usando un quantum circuit
per generare campioni di esempi
che poi post-processeremo
e diagonalizzeremo tramite una serie di algoritmi
in questa famiglia di routine
come SQV, SKG e SKG, per cui esiste un intero corso
sulla piattaforma IBM Quantum dedicato
a questi e ai metodi correlati
per i nostri scopi in questa sezione
daremo una spiegazione breve
indipendentemente da che tu stia usando SQV o SKG
il tuo obiettivo è trovare gli autovettori
e gli autovalori di una matrice hamiltoniana
questa matrice può descrivere l'energia di un sistema fisico
o chimico, ma lo stesso framework
può affrontare molti altri tipi di problemi
come la logistica. A volte
queste matrici sono enormi
quindi ridurre le dimensioni
della matrice preservando al contempo le caratteristiche importanti
dello stato fondamentale
può essere estremamente prezioso: questo è l'obiettivo in SQV
usiamo il computer quantistico per generare un sottospazio utile
che contenga lo stato fondamentale
possiamo quindi proiettare la nostra matrice hamiltoniana
su quel sottospazio, il che ci lascia
con una matrice ridotta che sarà
molto più facile da diagonalizzare
usando il calcolo classico ad alte prestazioni. Lo facciamo
preparando uno stato quantistico di prova
spesso chiamato ansatz
ed eseguendo misurazioni per campionare quell'ansatz
nella base computazionale. Questo ci fornisce
un sottospazio campionato nella base computazionale
ma quello che vorremmo davvero trovare
è il vero stato fondamentale. E se
il nostro sottospazio campionato non contenesse
tutte le componenti necessarie?
Se scegliessimo un ansatz migliore
potremmo ottenere una stima migliore dello stato fondamentale
questo ci porta al campionamento basato su
Krylov quantistico o SKUDY. In SKUDY
partiamo da un ansatz
come prima, ma poi applichiamo alcuni quantum gate che approssimano
l'evoluzione temporale di un sistema fisico
si può dimostrare che, con alcune assunzioni,
questo porta a garanzie sulla sovrapposizione tra l'ansatz evoluto nel tempo
e il vero stato fondamentale
entrambi questi algoritmi partono da enormi
matrici hamiltoniane e funzionano in modo leggermente diverso
ma in entrambi i casi la parte quantistica dell'algoritmo produce
un sottospazio che ci permette di ridurre la nostra matrice
preservando, si spera, le caratteristiche chiave dello stato fondamentale
quindi dove entra in gioco il calcolo classico ad alte prestazioni?
Per le hamiltoniane più grandi
e per le stime più accurate dello stato fondamentale
anche queste matrici proiettate possono essere piuttosto grandi
quindi sfruttare capacità di calcolo classico più potenti
può aiutarci non solo
a ottenere risultati migliori
ma anche permettendoci di affrontare problemi più grandi
per mettere tutto insieme
possiamo rappresentare gli algoritmi basati su campionamento
come una combinazione di diversi modelli di programmazione
su un insieme di risorse eterogenee
per esempio possiamo rappresentare il nostro algoritmo
come un flusso di lavoro a task, dove avremo un task
per la preparazione del quantum circuit che si sovrappone
al nostro stato target, seguito da un task
per il transpiler, che richiede solo risorse classiche
per essere eseguito. Successivamente ci sarà il task
che usa le primitive per eseguire il nostro quantum circuit
che ovviamente
e poi avremo un task di post-processing che a sua volta
potrebbe essere un algoritmo di diagonalizzazione parallela
in esecuzione su più nodi
inoltre potremmo voler eseguire
uno di quegli algoritmi molte volte
mentre variamo il nostro ansatz
oppure eseguirli completamente in parallelo
con popolazioni diverse
ora mettiamo tutto insieme con SKUDY
nel codice. Ecco tutti i nostri file di task
e qui tutti i nostri file di submission
nel task di mapping prepariamo i circuit.
Nello step di ottimizzazione eseguiamo i circuit nel modo migliore.
Nel task di esecuzione campioniamo le bistrings
dallo stato preparato dal
nostro ISA circuit.
Quello che otteniamo dallo step precedente
ed eseguiamo il nostro post-processing.
Ora siamo pronti a sottomettere il nostro
flusso di lavoro.
Come puoi vedere, tutto è scritto in sequenza
con le dipendenze. Aspettiamo
i risultati e possiamo controllare i file di output.
Ecco il file aperto dello step di ottimizzazione
dove abbiamo il nostro ISA circuit.
E infine controlliamo il nostro numero di iterazioni.
iterazioni.
Dallo schedule.
E questo è tutto per la rapida dimostrazione del flusso di lavoro SKUDY.
Tutto il codice sarà disponibile nella sezione testo
o nella descrizione qui sotto
e questo è tutto. Abbiamo ora esaminato alcuni
concetti ed esempi che possono aiutarti ad iniziare con
la gestione di programmi ibridi complessi. Naturalmente
se ti è piaciuto, questo scalfisce solo la superficie di
tutto quello che puoi fare con la combinazione di risorse quantistiche
e classiche. Per esplorare di più
dai un'occhiata alla documentazione e ai tutorial
sulla piattaforma IBM Quantum
e assicurati di controllare le risorse condivise nella sezione testo
o nella descrizione per ulteriori materiali
e software. Grazie per aver guardato.
Sì.